[Music]  my friend's in harm's way right now i  want to do whatever i can to help  our only option is to infiltrate the  power plant and interrupt the empire's  interference without the power of kings  on our side but who needs the power of  kings  when you have the power  of assassins  you think i'd let you leave that hunk of  junk in my plant you'd better think  again you can't come in here and  manhandle our power supply it takes a  woman's touch  your physician does not afford you the  right test we provide you with peace and  yet still you rebel it is high time you  learn to show some gratitude  [Music]  i thought you might show up get him  i can't take this much longer  oh we should have asked you for a plan  [Music]  you